heavenly Islands want to thank you for
this day life my heart is all full of
joy for these women right here lord
please make sure that Leafers don't get
an STD and that nobody has kidney fail
you if we're gonna get messed up and let
me get pregnant by somebody rich that's
my last Amy we haven't hung in five
years and yet you guys we need a girls
trip that's what car
not anymore baby is just without my
titties you know okay a titty I'll take
a 2d for a bike ride you sure you want
to get turned this weekend with your
girl they say the set of love free stuff
if you are going to come along with
those previous refrain from saying
things like preach or go girl or any
other colloquialisms that you may have
looked up on urban dictionary go back
this weekend is about us we deserve this
so let's go I hope to Pete look the line
is short over there there's a long line
in a bathroom here just golf boys
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I've known about this for a few months
kale that's in the past
said she was taking last night we need
to go clean nothing you need to say to
her that you came saying on a bus beg my
pardon just paddle in a ball today is
the last day that we will ever be this
young I have not had this much fun in so
long
wait I got what you need right here this
is 200 year old acid you drink too much
of it it will have you hallucinate you
coming to get me Josh you know I got
some bomb-ass cush if you want to take a
hit
we need you hat with a friend don't
shine you know what second cause of
Lyman section girl you can get no
infection in your booty ho it's a bunch
of
[Music]
[Applause]